hello everybody would you like to meet
a very good girl
this is my foster dog who is currently
laying down very submissively
she loves a belly scratch
huh what are you doing
what are you doing what's going on there
you go if you've been following the
channel for a while i definitely said um
as soon as i got a bigger place that i
wanted to start fostering dogs and i
basically did it as soon as i had stuff
unpacked um she is my first foster and
she is just so gorgeous but i do need
one of you to adopt her
so the shelter calls her queen bee but
she doesn't come to it because she was a
stray
and then was in the shelter for a long
time um and she is obviously if you
couldn't already tell a shepherd mix and
she's beautiful
continuing
so let me tell you a little bit more
about her i would say that her number
one priority in life is just a good pat
just a good scratch right on the nose
makes her
so happy
she's very happy to just lay next to me
and sleep for most of the day when i'm
working then we'll just occasionally
kind of
plot our way over demand another pat and
then go back to sleep
in some very strange positions actually
one of my single favorite things about
her since she's gotten more comfortable
with me since leaving the shelter is
that she's so like dorky and clumsy and
awkward considering her size and as much
she loves a nap i would say she is
probably a medium energy dog she does
need a lot of walking of course she's a
german shepherd she is also very playful
does have a very cute playful side
she likes chewing toys she's a big fan
of like any kind of fluffy toy more so
than fake bones or whatever and
she likes playing tug-of-war
sometimes she just um wants to be
directly on top of you while chewing
something and i'm not in a position
where i feel like i can say no to that
she does have high anxiety and we'll get
to that at the end of the video because
there are some disclaimers that i should
give for any potential adopters so that
you know people take it seriously and
don't just look at a pretty face and go
yeah i can take that dogs are of course
a lot of work but there are situations
in which she is so calm that it is
fantastic um she is an excellent car dog
she basically sits in the passenger seat
like an actual passenger is very chill
so happy to be in the car she's also
very good on a leash with other dogs
just walks past them doesn't really care
most of the time sometimes if another
dog box she will bark back at them but
i've never seen her initiate anything
good girl
good girl
i know he's a bit grumpy
i know
she doesn't care
hello
hi
um other things that you would need to
know about this big beautiful girl
obviously she's a shepherd mix we don't
know what she's mixed with
um she's definitely a longer-haired
shepherd she's got a lot of fluff needs
a lot of brushing but she's very very
sweet when being brushed obviously very
big lap dog sometimes she's just like a
rag doll she'll just kind of hang out
she will probably fall asleep like this
just grab your butt come on get you more
comfy there you go you big baby how
would anyone not want this in their life
you know look how cute she is it's
ridiculous she does have a medical issue
called um i believe it goes by epi it's
not that uncommon especially in
shepherds and it means that she can only
eat specific food and you have to
prepare it in a specific way so
i actually don't think any of that is
very difficult she basically has to eat
food that is good for sensitive dogs
and you have to put a powder on it a
pancreatic enzyme powder you mix it in
with some water and then you leave it
for
15 20 minutes sometimes i leave it for a
little bit longer um sometimes i'll just
make the food before we go for a walk
and then give it to her when we get back
so that could be 45 minutes sometimes
it's not hard to do and then you feed it
to her if she eats things that aren't
under that specific diet she basically
won't absorb any of the calories on
nutrients which means she could have
like eight meals a day and still starve
to death so you do have to give her
medicated food but i don't have any
problem with that really it is more on
the expensive side so that is obviously
worth noting it does cost more money you
would need to be able to budget for your
dog to have a medical issue which to be
fair
you should do 100 of the time anyway
dogs are expensive regardless but that
is something worth noting out the jump i
actually kind of find it convenient
because it means like
shepherds do well on a schedule and my
life is easier if things are very
specifically scheduled that like she
gets three meals a day and i know when
to give it to her and she doesn't eat
treats or snacks outside of that she
can't have any human food which means
she doesn't drool when you eat around
her she still definitely needs a little
bit of training for some things like
she'll still try to get up in your face
if you have food to sniff it that's a
thing that virtually any dog that hasn't
been trained will do though but she
doesn't drool because she never gets any
she has no reason to salivate because
she won't ever actually eat any food
that isn't um specifically for her but
yeah it does mean that you can't give
her like a lot of the common dog snacks
like a bully stick or a specific kind of
bone or whatever but she's doing pretty
well with it um and
you know for an owner there are some
things that are a little bit easier like
you can start experimenting with
different kinds of food i'm as a foster
only allowed to give her what the
shelter gave me
so i have to stick to exactly that but
you do have like a couple of other
options for things that can work
otherwise i mean she's just so beautiful
it's ridiculous i know that i'm gonna
have a bunch of people in the comments
say be like why don't you just adopt her
i don't understand
that's not the point of fostering my
friends
fostering is um
people have been like surprisingly
critical of it in a way that it's like
odd because
i'm doing something nice you know if in
my head i'm doing something that's good
but people have been very critical of me
for not
adopting her but that's not the point of
fostering
fosters basically
take dogs out of shelters until they get
adopted so you train them and you get
them out of that anxious environment and
you get them
used to being around people and
socialize and she's been around a lot of
people and a lot of dogs and it also is
just like a much better life for them um
until they get adopted at which point
somebody takes them and i intend to keep
fostering i think the point where i
would adopt a dog just to talk about
myself and not about her is uh
when i think i am perfect for them it's
not when they're perfect for me she's
beautiful and i love her but i know that
i am not good for her um so if i had a
foster dog that i was like i'm aware
that this dog needs me and that i am
ideal and can give them their ideal life
that's the point where i would adopt but
that is not the case for her um i
definitely know that she needs multiple
people she needs
either other dogs or a family she's much
more anxious when the two of us are
alone versus if she's in a house with
multiple people i've gone and stayed at
friends places and brought her with me
she's just so much calmer and more at
ease and clearly happier with a lot of
people around or other dogs around i
think that um well i actually spoke to a
german shepherd behaviorist about this
by chance and they said that she's a dog
who has anxiety which is the same as
human anxiety it's not like for no
reason like she's diagnosed anxiety
disorder she has anxiety so she's an
anxious dog and the fact that she they
think was a stray and then was in the
shelter and has been with me it means
that her entire identity is just tied to
making sure that i'm alive right now
because they're also guard dogs and
herding dogs and that is a lot of stress
whereas if you have multiple people like
a family or a household or multiple dogs
it would mean that she can get used to
an ecosystem when she feels like
everybody is taking care of everybody
and that she's being taken care of and
that other people are always with other
people whereas just one person
is stressing her out and i am just one
person meaning i don't feel like i have
the means to make her flourish and give
her the best family i think that she'd
be so so so happy with multiple people
um what else have i not covered she's
very clumsy and it's like one of the
cutest things about her she's so clumsy
she'll like slide all over the floor
sometimes when she stretches after a nap
she'll like kind of fall over she's so
cute just because she doesn't have a
grip on the floor because my floors are
all wood here so she'll just like slide
and fall over she trips on herself it's
all very very cute and has no
destructive behaviors despite her
clumsiness like obviously bringing a dog
in the house i was worried about like
what's gonna happen to my toys and she's
chewed a couple of the books that were
behind me here that used to be in that
bookcase but
that's it never touched any collectibles
or anything like that nothing that's um
been on the floor
doesn't chew clothing doesn't chew socks
none of that kind of stuff she does love
chewing water bottles does love chewing
water bottles something about the
plastic obviously you have to make sure
that they don't swallow it but she never
does she's also um not reactive in terms
of like i could just take stuff out of
her mouth like obviously the medical
issue you need to make sure that she
doesn't eat other things other food you
can literally just put your whole hand
in her mouth and she'll just let you
take it she doesn't growl and i've had
plenty of big dogs made rottweiler when
i was a kid was probably the worst word
who would growl at me call it resource
guarding and i understand why dogs do it
they want to eat their food they don't
want you to take it away from them but
she doesn't have any of those behaviors
at all she will occasionally bark at
strangers um it seems to be pretty
specific to people who are startled by
her it's definitely only men she doesn't
bark at women at all um never and there
is no racial component tends to be worse
for people who are tall
um and i list that because some dogs can
unfortunately kind of be racist she
doesn't seem to have any of that
everyone gets it equally if they're tall
it's slightly more of a problem but the
behavior is generally
if somebody seems to be afraid of her
then um
it's in her dna to go they're afraid
they must be doing something wrong
i should investigate so you can't fault
her for just trying to do her job but
all she ever does is bark oh that was a
big sigh what do you would pay taxes or
something what do you got to say about
yeah if uh if the person who she's
barking at approaches or whatever she'll
just sniff them and then just stop but
she does have some like behavioral
quirks that i think virtually all
shelter dogs have that with love and
training i have no doubt that this dog
will be perfect for somebody's home
she's so sweet and loving and
affectionate and like just wants to
please humans so bad she's really easy
to train even though you can't give her
treats because she just wants your
approval she just wants you to be happy
um she's very receptive to positive
feedback in terms of like tone of voice
she's also very receptive to no she
definitely understands it it took me two
days to basically teach her that she's
not allowed to jump up on the couch
she'll still try every now and then but
just with the front two paws not the
whole body
my number one favorite thing that she
does is in the morning she'll sleep in
with me and she's great about it and
she's fully house trained she's perfect
it took a week and a half she'll wait
until midday which is if i sleep in
she'll wait but in the morning usually
she'll like hear my alarm go off and so
she knows then that's me waking up and
then she'll come over to the bed and
just put her head on it she'll just rest
her head on the bed and look at me then
i have to give her some pats and then i
when i get up she starts wagging her
tail and gets excited because i mean she
gets to go for a walk or she gets to
have food hello darling i love big girl
big sleepy lady you're beautiful oh my
gosh she gets very tired after a walk
and the shelter guess that she was for
but i would guess that she's maybe two
and a half or three because she still
does have some puppy energy not a ton
like i said she's not destructive she
doesn't do zoomies she doesn't go nuts
um she's pretty manageable but she does
have some puppy energy in a more than i
would have thought for a four-year-old
dog don't you don't you he's still a
little playful dog and the vibe is like
she generally doesn't really care
about most dogs i've never seen her care
about cats she doesn't really care about
people except for the people she gets to
know at first she's just like
uninterested in most stimulus she
doesn't really care except for the
people that she's gotten to know so like
people i've had her around a lot she now
gets very excited when she sees them
obviously she cares about me a lot i
would say it takes her probably like two
days of seeing somebody for her to get
an attachment to them otherwise it's not
negative behavior it's just like
uninterested behavior like she just
doesn't really [ __ ] with them she's so
gorgeous isn't she a big beautiful girl
isn't she
she likes to chase her tail
big fan of that it's how she
communicates she'll chase the tail if
she needs to pee or if she wants to go
for a walk um that's how she lets you
know that she's thinking about something
and she sometimes has a frustrated bach
which is my favorite like just a real
playful cute bark so she doesn't bark a
lot what she can she does have pretty
bad separation anxiety very common for
shelter dogs common for puppies hers is
a little bit harder to manage than um
some other dogs of course shelter dogs
it is just harder for them in general i
get why it's hard they've had a tough
time but that's because you can't
distract her with food uh if the the
separation anxiety kicks in a lot of
dogs you just like give him a treat or
something doesn't work for her she
doesn't care she will just cry the whole
time i've slowly been training it out of
her and she is getting better every
single day getting better and better and
better and sometimes it's mood dependent
if she's like feeling especially anxious
it'll be a little bit worse again very
common thing not not unique to her she
is an anxious dog so the separation
anxiety is something that's basically
just like if you leave the house she'll
cry or potentially try to escape because
she thinks that you've locked her in
there alone so i would suggest um what
you're supposed to do which is very hard
to do for one person like if i have to
go to a doctor's appointment or
something it's difficult you are
supposed to slowly ease them into
getting used to you not being there so
leave for literally one second one day
and shut the door between and then three
seconds and then five seconds i would
say i can right now do about a minute
before she freaks out though sometimes
if she's like had a really big walk and
then i leave and i put her in her crate
because i'm currently crate training her
i think she could be okay for 15 20
minutes under those circumstances but it
is something that she she needs help on
so she'd probably do great with somebody
who's home all the time and i am home a
lot just you know again i am one person
i have to go out sometimes but that's a
training thing that definitely is
ongoing um i've been leash training her
and she's doing so well she was really
bad puller at the start and i would say
she's still not walking like right next
to me which is supposed to be the ideal
but she's pretty damn close she just
loves sniffing so she'll always walk
around and just sniff a bunch of stuff
but she um she's gotten so much better
on the leash so so so far she's just
really quick to train it's kind of what
i'm saying she's a beautiful dog she's a
big beautiful dog
i mostly have largely like very positive
things to say about her essentially um
yeah some minor behavioral issues
obviously medical issue but none of it
is for her she's a beautiful dog i just
wanted to be in a house with like a lot
of people or a family or other dogs just
so that she has company and she can
start to feel more confident and more at
home and like like one person isn't her
sole responsibility um so that that
anxiety gets a little bit more
manageable and yeah thank you for
watching if you would like to adopt
queen bee check out the link in the
description she's from pasadena humane
and i'm gonna continue to foster dogs is
the plan so i will foster another dog
and i will like kind of learn their
behaviors and let you guys know who they
are and who i think they would fit for
and this beautiful girl just needs a lot
of love somebody will give her a lot of
love and a lot of cuddles clearly she's
very content with cuddles
very large lap dog but
i wouldn't have it any other way thank
you for watching good luck to my sweet
baby queen bee as they call her finding
a home
you're gonna be great everybody loves
you
you're gonna be great oh thank you